[Music]
hi and welcome back to vm end to end a
show where we have a vm skeptic myself
and a vm enthusiast or vm enthusiast
come on to the show to talk about why
vms are cool interesting and useful for
a cloud native future
last time we talked about
reasoning about reliability but i feel
like i still don't know enough to
actually do anything with it in the real
world so we've brought steve and brian
back on today to help hammer that out hi
steve hi brian thanks for being here hey
carter nice to be here
glad to have you brian i got to start
with you buddy
after last week's episode do you think i
know enough to actually go and like take
a
small sas offering and go from like
three nines reliability to four nines to
maybe five nines
so i think we've got a lot of the
components we talked about you know some
of the patterns that are common um
we can dig into that a little more as
well but
you know the the question is kind of
like
when and how so what if we got a little
more specific here like what what kind
of app are you imagining
you know building okay
let's let's go with the payment
processing app uh so it's a sas
application it's gonna exist in the
cloud people do payments um
right now that's mostly what it's gonna
focus on
i guess it's to be honest i don't even
know how to reason about how reliable
that is by itself so i guess we should
start there steve
yeah this is a this is a good place to
start like i think using uh in sre we
call this a non-abstract systems design
problem which which is the best way to
do it and i i think um if you think
about this like
you're you're building a system on your
laptop probably or on your you know your
desktop you're you're getting it
functionally correct first and then you
have to think about like how much do i
want to invest in into it in order to
scale it up to have it like do something
for someone else because like having it
just like run tests on your laptop
doesn't really make you a lot of money
doesn't do much good for society you
want to get it out there right you want
to put it into production and so what
you really have to do is think about
like well you know how how reliable do i
want it to be and the answer should
always be just reliable enough
right that's kind of a jokey way of
responding but like think about like you
know who your customers are like what do
they really need out of this so you're
talking about a payments processor right
so like who are your customers like is
your customers like your friend who you
know sells bracelets at the farmer's
market or is it like a fortune 500
company who's like gonna be like
throwing you know transactions at you
all all the time from around the world
it's going to be very different
situations you know what i mean
okay so i love i love this uh specific
thing so
it's always a business kind of trade-off
or a goals kind of trade-off is the is
the takeaway here totally um
do you have do you have any like rules
of thumb for how do you how do you know
because of business thing they care
about like money and time like how do
you know
like when we're moving between these
thresholds how much
is that
we don't have a lot of good data it's
more just like a a sense you know like
um but the the the rule of thumb that we
use is that every additional nine you
add to a system is going to cost you 10
times as much as the last one did so if
you move from like 90 available just
like running on your laptop and you
close the lid and it's not available
anymore to moving on to the cloud where
the vm the single vm that it's running
on is like 99 or actually more like 99.9
available um
you know it's gonna it takes more effort
and and the way to reason about it is
really like uh 10x per nine so um
that's huge it's a big deal that i like
i like this little simple like heuristic
for me to reason about it uh but i guess
i'm still a little bit lost in
like like take the internet
how reliable is the internet can we
ground it uh maybe these nines and and
just like you know a simple like
browsing the web kind of thing how
reliable is that
yeah um great question um have you ever
turned off your phone
rarely but yes yeah like the battery
dies sometimes right like like phones
kind of like lose connectivity like you
ever been in a dead spot like maybe
maybe sometimes right so like your phone
doesn't have 100 reliability in terms of
letting you do stuff on the internet um
so if you think about it that way like
if you're building a system just for
yourself on the cloud you wouldn't want
to invest in making it five nines or
viable because like your pipe to that
service is over like your phone and like
you know cell towers and stuff and
you're gonna be driving through a tunnel
sometimes and so like why make a five
nine service for a three nines tunnel
and this before you go too far with this
analogy though the the reason why we
start to
um have higher availability is because a
lot of these services are actually for
server to server communication in in a
data center where they have much better
connectivity than you do between your
your computer or your um phone and a
service
and the other part of it is like most of
the time you have more than one customer
so like if my connectivity to the
service is no good most of the other
people's services actually still good
during during that minute or during that
second right so you really do want to
have for like these high-end services
you want to have them pretty highly
available but you have to think of the
big picture like who's the customer how
many of the customers are there how
often do they expect it to be up or not
and the last thing you want to consider
is like
your service or like your business or
whatever is probably made up of a bunch
of different services and so if you have
many endpoints that your service might
or that your your customer may hit some
of them might be super important some of
them might be way less important so if i
need to like sign up for a new account
and it's down like i can i can retry not
a big deal but like if i'm sending you
like thousands of transactions per
second and i want you to like give me
money back
that should probably be more up than
than the sign up flow you know what i
mean okay so this makes sense so we're
we're we're building this kind of more
reliable system out of layers of less
reliable bits and because we have lots
of users that our business needs to do
it but like
so we talked about a little bit of it
like in the docs you can find out
roughly how reliable a vm is but when
you start to build these shapes on top
of that
how do i know
even roughly you know kind of
how reliable a particular pattern that
i've you know built is you know load
balancer in front of a vantage instance
group or something yeah um great great
question because most
interesting businesses at least that i
know of are not running on a single vm
right they're not just like one thing um
and if you look at the cloud offerings
there's all kinds of stuff you know
there's like pub sub and databases and
all kinds of stuff and your job as uh
like a you know an architect or a
designer or an engineer at a at a
company who's using the cloud is to come
up with what we call an architecture
right so this is this is the set of
services that all kind of stick together
some of them are like you you put code
onto a compute platform of some kind
another one is like you put a schema
onto a database or a data store of some
kind um sometimes it's like a message
passing so you have to define the
message queues so this this is your
architecture so the the trick with
architecture is you've got a whole bunch
of components and you can compose them
in tons of different ways and some of
them are complete
disasters right like some of them do not
work well um so now uh
the question you asked is like how do we
know if we're building a good one and
just like any software development uh
the best plan is is to use like a a
well-known pattern um so we have like
these design patterns in computer
science we have similar design patterns
in in cloud architecture as well so
there's actually a paper that came out
um sometime this year a while ago and it
was um about the we call it the
deployment archetypes in cloud
and it gives you a couple
like i think there's like six or eight
different models and you know it starts
off simple like you know build one thing
in one region and and it builds up from
there so some of the more common
architectures are like if you have a
stack of services
and by services i mean like you know
your your web server and your database
and um things like that you can have one
stack in one region and one stack in
another region and like a load balancer
in front of those two things um and you
can get really complicated beyond that
you can you can have
things like failover between those two
be automated you can have like hot and
cold you can have hot and warm you can
have hot and hot and you can have like
more than just two right you could have
n different deployments and have them
all be active at any given time and you
can you know charge your customers
across them and all that so um take a
look at that paper it's
not um
like gcp architecture specific it gives
you the pattern though that that lets
you know what you can get out of this
this archetype i love that and i love
just learning general principles for how
to architect and design systems so i'm
definitely going to check that out
but
now this kind of leads me to this
question of
calling back something you said earlier
getting a little less abstract
if i were to take my payment processor
application it was you know just for
myself and my friends before now i've
got my first big customer and they you
know they're gonna throw thousands of uh
receipts and invoices at me
what what like how do i start analyzing
going from where my offering is at to
where it needs to be now to meet these
demands i love pinning it to this real
problem and and the the pattern you're
talking about where you start with a few
customers and you slowly grow
and you start to make like business
agreements with more customers that is
common across all everybody right this
is this is totally how businesses grow
um and it's the right way to do it
because you don't want to start in your
garage and build like enterprise
software and expect it to be like you
know you're going to spend 15 years
building this thing before you have your
first customer so so growing with your
customer demands is totally the right
way to do it
uh in terms of actually getting you to
be able to like land that contract with
you know big co um and and handle the
you know the five nines or whatever it
is that they're you know putting in your
contract um this takes a lot of what we
call like resilience engineering or
reliability engineering um the way to
think about it is that you're going to
be building what we call a platform and
this is going to be a platform of
capabilities so these capabilities are
going to be technical things like you
can
deploy code to your to your services you
know quickly and effectively and safely
so you've heard of ci cd for example
like a ci cd pipeline is a set of
capabilities in your platform uh other
things like observability and monitoring
so being able to determine like what is
going on right now like why is this one
weird thing slow like being able to look
at a graph and being able to like drill
into it and be able to like check out
you know a trace or like a profile of a
live running system and being able to
understand it like having your team be
able to like grok what's really going on
under the covers and use the tools that
they have at their disposal this is all
part of your platform when you're
building out capabilities as a team to
to be able to like run this super
complicated complex system
and the more capabilities you have the
the better shot you have it at achieving
it so if we want to be able to handle
our requests from kind of bigco coming
in like everything downstream of that
needs to be
like highly reliable to the same same
degree right
this is this is a great like um the
answer is no like it's one of these
surprising things where you're what
really matters to your business is the
front door right so uh you know bigco
has a contract with us and whenever they
send us a thing we have to be able to
respond within some amount of time but
does that mean that like the database
behind our api needs to be like six
nines and like the infrastructure that
that database is on needs to be like
seven nines and then like does the power
supply behind that i've never even heard
these numbers like 19 nines like what's
going on this is this is untenable right
um and the answer is totally no like
that is not the case um so this is this
is good news so you're able to to build
things that are more reliable on top of
things that are less reliable this is
this is like a general abstraction that
you can achieve so if your front door
you want it to be five nines you can get
away with having like a four nines or
even a three nines back end and the way
you do that is through some resilience
capabilities so like a really really
simple one is purely uh adding retries
to your system so if your front end is
up and your back end is down briefly
when your front end makes a request to
your back end and it goes little error
instead of like
returning the response to your you know
the the customer that you have an
agreement with like i don't know what
happened like that's a bummer
just wait you know just just wait for
200 milliseconds or some amount of time
and try it again if it still doesn't
work wait a little longer so uh as long
as you're not exceeding some sort of
like contractual deadline you can wait
all day and you can still give back a
correct response and the customer will
see that as a success so this is another
form of how we kind of hide errors
behind layers of abstractions
and it's it's
basically you're trading off in this
case you're trading off time for
reliability and if that's okay with your
business
do it it's just another like
you know tool in your toolbox i love
this idea of basically planning for the
imperfect we talked about this when we
talked before
and i'm sure there's a bunch of
different avenues that we could go and
look at this like uh like geography
there could be points of failures there
or like you said with time using time is
a trade-off
um
the thing i'm really curious about is it
sounds like
there's a lot that goes into this you
talked about a team of people having to
be involved and you yourself are an sre
so it seems like there's more than just
technology and i've been very focused on
that but there's there's also people
involved and maybe there's even other
elements involved in this reliability
can you can you talk about that a little
bit yeah um
when we talk about you know large
systems we tend to say you know people
process and technology so this is a
great example of it
so being able to
understand a system improve the system
and build the system is it's it's being
done by humans right and um the the
model that google came up with is called
sre so a lot of these principles that
google used to to build these systems
out and to scale them up and and not
burn out all the humans in the meantime
um has all been written down and like
the the specifics of of what google
series would do in the past inside of
google um don't apply directly to what
customers would do because it's like an
entirely different system and like you
know customers aren't running web search
on borg or anything like that right
they're running you know payments
processors on kubernetes on you know
cloud
but the principles are actually the same
and the principles can be applied uh
anywhere they're they're totally
consistent so
all of this bundled together not just
the tools but also the the process
and the the culture right you know how
that how people work with each other uh
we kind of bundle that together as as
sre um and so this is this is uh there's
a bunch of books out there that you can
get that explain all this um and it's
it's becoming more and more popular
so awesome so we'll definitely put some
some links to the sre books and um the
article you mentioned earlier in the in
the show notes here
um so we've got
like as far as doing this like when you
want to actually like kind of push your
app like up you know to another
threshold of nines um we've got you know
the
people process tech
part
and then we've got this you know
reliability patterns and some of those
patterns
i think are built into the system like
we talked about last time you know that
like are kind of in the vm abstraction
and some of them are things we have to
handle with our app architecture itself
does that sound fair totally
um you you know you can there's always
the idea of build versus buy
and um a lot of these systems
you're just kind of getting out of the
platform so these capabilities that i
talked about
if you're running on-prem on machines
that you bought you know a couple years
ago and you're running you know your own
software on them you're not going to get
live migration out of it you could build
it it might take a while or something
like it right
but if you instead if you kind of
take that concern and you hand it off to
cloud you get this capability so
there's a lot of things out there that
you can kind of
get a product right and that gives you
that capability for your platform and
now you can do that thing
another similar one is like if you have
the
layer 7 load balancer a global l7 load
balancer you're able to siphon traffic
from one region to another like kind of
magically it's amazing and doing this
like on the wild west internet is really
hard because it's like you got to deal
with different autonomous systems and
bgp and dns and all this crazy stuff but
like with um google's l7 load balancer
it's pretty straightforward and you take
advantage of this massive set of of
systems out there this front-end
technology that google uses for its
entire set of services i've got to thank
you steve and brian this is my first
time that diving into sre principles and
the thinking behind reliability and so i
learned so much whether it's about the
people in the process and the technology
whether it's about having uh
non-abstract or less abstract like
architectures and really thinking
through it uh so thank you i'm gonna
definitely check out that uh
that uh paper about all the different
patterns and for people listening at
home
if you check that paper out tell us in
the comments what you liked or didn't
like about it thank you so much
[Music]